are you still playing street fighter 5
well if you were looking forward to
trying out the next dlc character that
I'm afraid I have some bad news for you
I'm Matt in this game spot news update
is not getting delayed hint hint street
fighter 5 s next dlc character imbalance
up they'd have both been delayed the
game's revamped online component capcom
fighters network recently went through a
beta test and while it showcased some
improvements like better matchmaking and
faster load times capcom wants to put it
through another test both the character
in the update were developed under this
new infrastructure so they'll have to
wait until that's ready unfortunately no
new release date has been revealed we'll
report back when it's announced so be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to stay up to
date on all the street fighter news the
next dlc character is currently unknown
however the next beta test will be
available in the coming weeks and once
it's live it will include access to all
existing fighters in addition to that
mysterious dlc character but if you
can't wait until then and you want some
fighting game action right now check out
the official breakdowns for gorilla
grodd and scarecrow in injustice to
[Music]
you